colegios como estos se han convertido en
el punto de encuentro de miles de
desplazados que llegan a esta ciudad de
iván o francos vista aquí la comunidad
se organizado para darles ropa cobijas
juguetes para los niños alimentos la
mayoría de esas personas tuvieron que
huir de sus ciudades apenas con lo
puesto y también vienen bastante
traumatizados hay una red de más de 100
psicólogos dispuestos a ayudarlos a que
inscriben su nombre y nos remiten a un
lugar especial
hablamos con quienes llegan sobre esos
miedos los apoyamos y les ayudamos no a
quitarse el temor sino a comprenderlo y
aceptarlo mucho quitarse de esta
situación es imposible pero saber cómo
comportarse apropiadamente es muy
importante
en la guerra en la región de donbass en
2014 ya había creado redes de apoyo de
psicólogas que daban soporte no
solamente a los desplazados sino también
a los soldados que pelearon allí y han
vuelto a reactivarse incluso con
psicólogas que llegan de ciudades que
están siendo atacadas
necesito trabajar porque me gusta mucho
mi profesión me gusta trabajar con niños
y adolescentes conocí la gente de este
centro y por eso he venido he traído los
juguetes y estamos listos para esperar a
los niños que vienen con sus mamás desde
kiev archiv para ayudarlos a relajarse y
bajar
números
también trabajamos con soldados de la
defensa territorial donde intentamos
enseñarles unos ejercicios prácticos que
les servirán para entender sus
reacciones y cómo tienen que comportarse
de lobios tras esta red de psicólogos se
distribuye durante el día en la estación
de tren por ejemplo o en colegios donde
acogen a a estos desplazados y como inés
por ejemplo así por órganos dice que si
bien muchos piden ayuda psicológica lo
que primero necesitan es arreglar sus
problemas esenciales que es por ejemplo
encontrar donde vivir que comer y qué
hacer mientras se acaba la guerra por lo
menos en las próximas semanas mientras
que tienen alguna noticia